all right we are at new york comic con
with amanda conner jimmy palmiotti how
are you two doing we do it great it's
great it's thursday at the first day of
the con come back sunday and see how we
are yeah it will be like skeletons you
know so the last time we talked i
believe it was when you first brought in
the new hairdo for harley and i asked
you if it was gonna stick around it
looks like it is sticking around so far
he has she has a mohawk in issue 5 6 and
7 so that gets kind of thrown out the
window in the new books and then her
hair has to grow back so it's short yeah
for a while so we're treating it like
real-time hair I don't know if anyone
else in comics does that but we're
treating our characters in real time
here yeah there's your headline hairline
there's a hairline by AJ I'd like now
how did i get like when you guys a tag
like let's give harley a mohawk who came
up with that well we we decided you know
we wanted to make put her in a punk rock
band and we thought oh well personally I
love when do Williams that look like you
know the only thing Harley is actually
missing is the electrical tape I think
or you know over there yeah we don't
have that on the we got red flag on that
we get rid of it but Jimmy I heard you
do that sometimes I do I have it right
now because I'm very sensitive to the
cold and they stick out and they
actually can like cut glass here you
know no actually no I don't want people
grabbing my nipples no at my nipples I
dig what do we why are we talking about
my numbers let's talk about Amanda's
nipples let's get Tony really in trouble
yeah all right parlays in a punk rock
band she goes undercover and forms a
punk rock band with the Tony eggy and
red tool and so it's our version of
point break where they're trying to get
into another bandits that's punk punk
break would have been a good name now
you come up with that all right anyway
uh so anyway um I guess lunch II guess
so so they she goes on the cover and she
shaves her head and makes a nice big
mohawk and and she's a lead singer and
she doesn't have a great voice yes she's
actually pretty bad yeah I think issue 6
she gets booed on stage and it's not
good for everyone that they did that and
yeah we're having fun we even have a
issue 8 we have a superhero and
supervision a supervillain fetish club
that's hidden Manhattan don't you want
to really see that I want to see that
for real you want like in the real world
yeah I I feel like cosplay is like one
step away from that sometimes not all
the time most of time is spent at but
once in a while you see something like
whoa like did they run out of fabric and
you know that kind of thing anyway
what's next for Harley after the punk
banner is can you not talk about it yet
well after all that work going
undercover she goes on vacation the
poison ivy and yeah cuz as you you know
as readers know she's been promising
poison ivy a vacation for the past what
like four or five issues or something at
least yeah yeah something like that and
which is what a week there come in every
other day but um what they don't know
that that everybody else is gonna find
out about is uh it's a nudist colony
it's a nice thing is it places that yeah
they get off the planet like all right
we ready for our vacation and it's a
senior's nudist colony yes something you
haven't seen in other comic books of DC
have you we and we have that coming up
and then we have a we have a story with
the Joker coming up after that that's
another three-part story so there's a
lot of fun stuff coming all right make
sure you look for harley quinn comics by
DS 2 and look for that nudists senior
citizen colonies and Grandpa greatest
use of word balloons for
Rupp you've ever seen in the comic